mais d'abord direction Chinon 11
personnes ont dû être relogées après un
départ de feu au niveau des caves de
leur immeuble le sinistre s'est déclaré
dimanche en début d'après-midi boulevard
Paul-Louis Courier une enquête a été
ouverte par la gendarmerie de Chinon
pour connaître l'origine de cette
incendie Sarago
une épaisse couche dessus recouvre
encore les murs de 7 immeuble dans ce
local il ne reste que des débris
carbonisés dimanche aux alentours de 14h
le sous-sol du bâtiment s'enflamme selon
les premières constatations le feu
aurait pris au niveau du garage à
poussette pour les habitants impossibles
de sortir il se réfugie sur leur balcon
en attendant les pompiers alerté par des
cris des voisins tentent une opération
de sauvetage on a voulu essayer de
rentrer dans l'appartement en mettant
des draps sur nous mouillés pour aider
d'aller chercher l'enfant et tout ça
mais on pouvait pas ce que dès qu'on
toucher la poignée quoi ça ne brûlait
carrément les doigts et c'est vraiment
c'était choquant si personne ont été
transportées vers l'hôpital pour des
risques d'intoxication liés à la fumée
elles sont toutes sorties indem en
trière et ce matin pour la moitié
d'entre elles il sera impossible
d'accéder à l'horlogements seuls les
habitants des deux premiers étages
pourront le retrouver la gendarmerie
nous a de regagner notre logement juste
pour
pour récupérer du linge des affaires des
papiers mais on n'a pas le droit de d'y
vivre une enquête a été confiée à la
gendarmerie de Chinon la piste
criminelle est actuellement privilégiée
des suspicions sont d'ailleurs avancées
par le voisinage et on a failli aussi
subir le même sort il y a un peu plus
d'un an et au mois de décembre on a nous
avons eu des squatteurs que nous avons
fait évacuer bien entendu aujourd'hui un
couple a regagné son appartement au
premier étage en attendant le diagnostic
cet autre personne ont été relogées chez
leurs proches et deux autres à l'hôtel